I received my cheek swab results for supplements, but you did not mention any dietary changes maybe
I didn't ask or driver change, which I'm fairly sure I did ask. If I if I didn't mention any
dietary changes or driver change then it didn't come up. So the only time I'll mention something is
when I'm tested it comes up and that's the same thing with the right frequency update. I think
that's the second part of this question. Also, I'll send you any right updates via email drop
box or flash drive or since you did mentioning about right updates. Perhaps you're happy with
what I currently have. Yes. So there wasn't any right updates that needed to be done. There wasn't
any dietary changes or changes to the driver and the cancer. So if there was that I mentioned that
and I tweak your diet. I don't know. I can try to remember like percentage of time that that happens.
I guess I couldn't really put a percentage of time that happens. Now I do believe from a philosophical
standpoint that cancer is always trying to change its fuel source and try to find another way to fuel
itself and take off and start growing again. Maybe that's why I mean we don't see that all that
often that that actually happens with people that their cancers take it off again saying the Lord for
that but that's typically when there's a dietary change that something else is driving that cancer
fueling that cancer. When a person is relatively stable with their cancer usually there is a
dietary change. So if I don't mention it on the cheek swab then it didn't come up. I always do check
for it. Same thing with right frequency changes.